[music]
Hi everyone. It's great to be here
connecting with everyone in Europe and
the entire robotics community. I'm
Karolina, an elite robotics at Google
Deep Mind. I'm going to be talking today
a bit about how Gemini can power the
next generation of helpful robots.
I think we all agree in this room that
robots today are doing incredibly useful
things. They're helping in manufacturing
lines. They're in logistics, in
automotive. They're navigating our moon,
and they're even doing really cool
acrobatics. However, these robots have
been programmed to do these particular
task sequences. They make a lot of
assumptions about everything in their
environment, every object that they
touch, or they might be remotely
operated by humans.
This makes robots today incredibly
bespoke still and difficult to deploy,
often taking many months in order to
deploy a new application or a new or a
new task only to have to do it all over
again when something changes about the
task. At Google Dem, we've always
believed that AI will transform robotics
in so we've been at the forefront of
building foundation models in order to
build and enable truly intelligent
general purpose robots.
What we mean by this is robots that can
go on any environment that can operate
across many different verticals, do a
broad range of tasks, and handle objects
they have never seen before.
We also mean robots that are intuitive.
So, anyone in their environment should
be able to task the robot, adapt the
robot, improve the robot.
This also means robots that are safer
because they understand what they're
trying to do. They understand the
context in which they're operating. If
anything changes, they can adapt because
they understand what has changed. And
these are robots that are drop in that
they come with a broad range of skills
that can adapt to objects and
environments. And more importantly, they
don't need to know everything from the
start because they can learn and improve
over time. This is what will transform
robotics from one application at a time
to the ultimate tool for humans in the
physical world. And this is what we care
about at Google Deep Mind. Our mission
at DeepMind is to build AI responsibly
to benefit humanity. And in the robotics
team, our goal is to bring this mission
from the digital screen into the
physical world in a way that is helpful,
that is safe, and that is empowering.
In fact, our goal at Google Demine is to
nothing less but to solve AGI in the
physical world. What does that mean
anyway? To solve AGI in the physical
world. Well, it means that we want to
build an AI that can in infuse a robot
with human level intelligence and
physical abilities so that robots can
understand the world and reason about it
the same way you and I can. Not only
that, but also take action to the
precision of a human expert. It also
means building an AI that can go into
any embodiment. We believe in a world
where there will be many different robot
types, each one of them evolving over
time and becoming a different robot. And
you want this AI to basically adapt and
maximize the potential through
intelligent control. And lastly, you
want an AI that can be deployed in the
real world. So it needs to handle all
the diversity and the noise and the
unstructuress and the everchanging
environments that live in the real world
in order to bring real tangible impact.
This is of course a very ambitious goal
but one that we've been after since the
inception of the team and over the last
few years we've introduced significant
advancements that have become table
stakes in the field of general purpose
robotics. For example, in 2022 we
introduced LLMs and VLNs into robots.
This was the first time that robots were
able to really understand semantically
their environment, understand objects
and plan using multimodal input. We've
also introduced transformers into
robotics. This usher a new area of
datadriven robotics.
We've also introduced in this set of
group set of work the concept of a VA or
a vision language action model that
enables robots to understand natural
language, understand their environment
and do more general actions.
And we've also shown what's possible
when it comes to um actually let me go
to the next one. We've also shown what's
possible when it comes to learning
highly dextrous behaviors like in the
tying shoelaces example, something we
didn't think we would see in our
careers, as well as introducing
reinforcement learning in simulation for
whole body control. And we shown this on
quadripets and little humanoids playing
soccer and on ping-pong robots. And this
is now the default for whole body
control in the entire industry.
Last year, building on this, we
introduced Gemini robotics. This is our
most advanced visual language action
model to power the next generation of
helpful robots. Gemini robotics, as you
can tell, it draws from Gemini's
multimodal world understanding and
brings it to the physical world by
adding actions as a new modality in
Gemini. So the same way that Gemini can
produce text and code and images, it can
now produce robot action sequences which
are essentially trajectories that move
the robot in a way that is general, that
is interactive, and that is dextrous.
The reason robots are not all around us
here today is because they cannot handle
generalization yet. If you change the
robot complete environment, you change
the task that it's trying to accomplish,
you change the objects that it's
interacting with, typically it falls
apart.
With Gemini robotics, the idea is that
they can use Gemini's world knowledge in
order to tackle a completely unseen
situation. A good example that I like to
to showcase this is this example coming
up right now on the right, the
basketball hoop. So, this is a toy that
our vision team, our video team brought
that day. So the robot had never seen
this toy. He's never seen anything
related to basketball. And our team
asked it to slam dunk the basketball
even though he's never seen that object.
He's never seen that kind of task. It
took a quarter of a second to decide
that meant put that small ball into that
basket. That is the kind of
generalization that we care about.
We also introduced with Gemini Robotics
1.5 agents into robotics. The reality is
most tasks in the real world are complex
and they take multiple steps to
complete.
In order to do this, we need to move
beyond single instruction following
which we can now do in a very general
way into agentic systems. This means
that it needs to be able to understand
what the human is trying to do and then
translate it into a sequence of steps
using whatever tools are available to it
including VAS. Let me just show you a
quick example of what this looks like in
a I'm not sure it's going to be audible,
but we'll see.
Hi, Aloha. Can you use my location and
sort the [music] objects into the
correct compost, recycling, and trash
bins?
>> To perform the sorting task based
[music] on San Francisco waste
guidelines, I will use the green bin for
compost, the blue bin for recycling, and
the [music] black bin for trash.
>> Here we have on ouric layers [music]
both control the robot and have access
to the internet. To sort the trash, it
had to look up the rules and look at
[music] the objects on the table, think
about where each object should go,
matching the rules that it had looked
up.
Can you guys hear me now? Okay, cool.
So, what you're seeing there is
essentially an agentic system that is
powered by two key AI models. A high
level reasoning layer called Gemini
Robotics ER. That's our agent that
understands the environment, understands
the natural language and it can speak
back to the human and reason about the
sequence of steps it takes along with
the VA. It can also use tools as you saw
earlier. It was pulling up from search
what are the rules to do that that task
on trash sorting. Let's talk a bit about
this model more. So this is a physical
agent with memory. On the left you're
seeing someone asking the robot to reset
the scene after making a bunch of
changes in that scene. So it has to
remember what the scene look like. It
has to understand what it means to reset
the scene and then carry out the
sequence of steps in order to achieve
it. Many people also use this model
simply as a perception layer or a
reasoning layer. So you can use it for
2D bounding box detection, 3D bounding
box pointing. You can ask to match all
the socks on that image on the right.
We've also in last month introduced
Gemini Robotics ER 1.6. This is our
safest and most advanced model for
robotics to date. In this model, we're
advancing three core capabilities.
Pointing, enhanced success detection, as
well as a new capability called
instrument reading.
Pointing is a pretty basic capability
for spatial understanding. You can use
it for identify all the objects in the
scene, count the hammers in the scene,
but you can do more complex queries like
find me all the objects that fit in a
backpack. This what you can see here is
the evolution of the model. only in the
last nine months or so. And you could
see that the model is now a lot more
confident about what's in the image
versus what's not. It's also more
confident exactly how many objects are
in that image. This is extremely useful
for cluttered environments in examples
like logistics where your your task is
to pick up just the top thing that is on
that pile or the top three things.
Another capability I'm incredibly
excited about is instrument rating. This
is a capability we discover with our
partners at Boston Dynamics, the spot
team who does inspection in all of the
the industrial facilities and they want
to read all the instruments. This model
has advanced instrument reading thanks
to something called agentic vision. What
that means is that the model can decide
if it wants to read this gauge, it can
take intermediate steps. It can decide
to zoom into the image to get a better
reading of that gauge. It could then
decide to use pointing and maybe code
execution in order to do some math and
figure out the exact value of each
interval in that gauge. And then once it
has a very accurate reading, it can use
his world knowledge or call another tool
to decide whether that gauge is within
normal reading. This is what we call
agentic vision. And in the last again
three to six months, it's dramatically
improved. We're now about 93%
performance on this test set. And these
are real images. You can see they're
very diverse. They're noisy. They're
small. This is from real world examples.
And then in combination with Boston
Dynamics, we deploy this on their
robots. So now all of their customers
are able to use this. So we're basically
integrating our Gemini Robotics ER
reasoning layer with Boston Dynamics
autonomy system in order to enable it to
do understand the environment,
understand every object, read every
instrument, and then interact with the
environment as they normally would. And
now Spot can also use Gemini
capabilities. It understands natural
language. It can read that board. It can
do the full sequence of tasks and
orchestrate them. And I guess apparently
you can take Kod for a walk as well.
Our goal is beyond the quadriped robots
to also integrate with Boston Dynamics.
Yeah, I'm not sure who's walking home
there. Our goal is to also integrate
with Boston Dynamics uh humanoid robot
Atlas in order to bring Atlas reasoning
and action capabilities and really
fulfill that promise of true general
purpose humanoids.
Let's talk a little bit about the VA.
This is our action model. As I mentioned
earlier, it takes visual input,
typically all the cameras available to
the robot. It takes natural language
input as a prompt. It could also
alternatively use propriception or
previous actions. And the output is
directly the robot control targets. This
can be specified different for different
robots. Sometimes they're the endeector
positions. Sometimes they're the full
joints of the robot. And then that
typically goes to the motor controllers
who translate that into motion. With
that model, we can control all of these
different robots. So this is the Frana
robot, the Aloha robot. We also can
control the electronic humanoid robot.
And in all these cases, it's doing a
broad range of tasks. It's responding to
natural language requests. So, it's
interactive and it's dextrous.
In the case of a humanoid, since I
mentioned uh the Apollo robot, it looks
a little bit more like this, the
picture. So, if you go and ask a robot,
hey, could you please put my groceries
away? What it will do is it will first
send that to the ER model, which is the
agent. It understands the environment.
it understands the input and then
translate that into the first step to
take. Then say that it says okay the
first thing is to take the baguette out
of the bag. It will then go and send the
text string take the baguette out of the
bag propreception and perception to the
model and the model will output the
trajectories to do this right and take
it out and then underneath there's a
whole body controller is an RL policy
that is of course tracking that VA and
ensuring that the robot stays stable.
The other thing is that these models
also have thinking. What that means is
that the model is generating text and
action tokens together and that enables
it to reason about what it's doing. So
in this video I have no agent. It's just
the VA. Let's see what it plays.
Previous Gemini Robotics version has
been tested over and over and over again
to put this banana into the bowl. This
is a very simple task. I'm going to
switch the model here and make the task
slightly more challenging.
So this is Gemini Robotics [music]
1.5. Aloha. Could you sort these fruits
into color matching plates? Sure, I can
certainly help you do that. Put the
green fruit into the green plate. We
enable it to think. It can perceive the
environment, different colors of the
object, different colors of the plate.
It will think step [music] by step and
then finish this multi-step task. Put
the banana into the yellow plate
>> at that. We have a lot more examples of
that if you go into our website. The
last piece is that these models can work
across embodiment as I mentioned. And
not only that, they can learn across
embodiment. So what I have here is the
same set of weights working on these
three different robots. And on the top
you can see how the robots get better.
This is the Apollo robot in blue after
learning from Aloha. And this was
because we had very little data at the
time on the Apollo robot and you could
just learn from the stuff that Aloha had
already learned.
All right, I'm going to go very quickly
since I have a few minutes left. What is
at the frontier? Certainly one of the
things we're working on is how to scale
learning. Everything that you're done
that you've seen today is essentially
learned through robotics teleoperation.
That means a human had to put on goggles
and gloves and was able to like move the
robot to teach it how to do a task. That
of course only scales with the number of
robots and the number of hours that you
have in the day. We've also like to
learn of course from videos the same way
humans do. We learned a lot from
watching others and then we practice a
little bit. That's the ultimate goal.
We're always working on that. And then
we also have areas in the middle like
you can learn from simulation better.
You could dramatically increase the
number of environments that you have.
You can learn from world models. I'll
just mention just a couple of these
examples. So today we we've have a long
history working in simulation with
Mojoko. But today we can now enable
completely new task families and
actually on board a completely new robot
in simulation first for manipulation
which was not the case before. And this
helps us accelerate generalization.
We've also have world models. Now, what
I have here is an image from Aloha on
the left and another from Aloha on the
right. One of them is real, one of them
is generated. Anybody cares to guess
which one is generated? The left one.
Anybody? Nobody. Right. One person. All
right. So, they were right. The right
one is generated. And more importantly,
it's just getting extremely hard to tell
which one it is. So in fact in our team
we always put a border around videos
that are generated because it's not hard
hard to tell. So we can use this of
course for data generation for all kinds
of different research threats around
world models and we also use it very
much on evaluation for safety policies.
So, as you can imagine, we take world
models, make them look like it's the
input is coming from a real robot, then
condition it on actions, and actually
roll out policies in that environment.
And then you can use it to do all kinds
of different scene evaluations. You can
use it to put hard situations in that
you don't want to do in real like put
your hand in there and see what happens.
Put a baby in there and see what happens
and it's all good. This is excellent for
safety evaluation.
The last piece is that obviously models
alone are not going to change the world.
You need to combine them with real
robots. So we're extremely grateful for
our partnerships with Boston Dynamics,
Agile Robot, and Uptronic. And we're
working together to advance the
state-of-the-art on general purpose
robots for humanoids in particular, but
also other robots. And then we also have
a trusted tester program. Many companies
here in the EU are in it. There's
actually a lot more than what shows
here. We've been working with Enchanted
Tools for a while. Generative Bionics is
also there. Bubble Robotics is also
there. There's quite a few pile robotics
is also there. Uh and then we now
started the EU accelerator to help bring
many different startups in the EU into
robotics and get them closer to
understanding how AI works and and
accelerating AI in their companies.
Now last many people ask me what the
futures of robotics looks like. I'm sure
we all here are dreamers extreme. I'm
extremely bullish when it comes to it.
It really depends how much effort we're
putting into really making this valuable
for humanity because that's what's
happen. That's what matters at the end
of the day. And AI is going to
accelerate this. It's going to make
robots more intuitive, more general,
more multi-purpose, safer. Of course, I
also believe the best way to predict the
future is to invent it. So, I'm
incredibly excited to be working in
robotics today. This is the best time to
be working in robotics and very excited
to be collaborating with all of you to
make this future possible. Thank you
very much.